this could be the story of the beginning
of the end of rubella the viral disease
that causes congenital defects in June
1969 the first rubella vaccine was
licensed this ended an eight-year search
for a vaccine by scientists and
physicians in University Medical
Center's private industry and government
the first breakthrough came in 1961 at
Harvard and Walter Reed with the
simultaneous isolation and
identification of the elusive rubella
virus by 1965 two scientists at the
National Institutes of Health had
developed an experimental vaccine which
seemed to prevent rubella yet not cause
or transmit the disease produced from
live rubella virus passed seventy-seven
times through green monkey kidney tissue
cultures the vaccine was called HPV 77
at NIH the experimental vaccine was
tested for purity and was grown in cell
cultures and quantity to permit
extensive laboratory studies before the
vaccine could be given to humans it was
tested repeatedly in hundreds of
laboratory animals by doctors Harry
Meyer and Paul Parkman the two NIH
scientists who developed HPV 77 at the
Children's Colony and Conway Arkansas
the vaccine was first given to humans 16
susceptible girls living in a quarantine
cottage after parents and school
officials gave permission for the study
eight girls were inoculated the others
served as controls the results were
encouraging the eight who were
vaccinated developed high antibody
levels but no symptoms nor did they
transmit the infection to the controls
but to speed the antibody tests a new
detection procedure was needed once
again the research of doctors Meyer and
park
was successful their new technique known
as the H I test in the hands of
qualified technicians now makes possible
the reliable measurement of rubella
antibody titers in three hours previous
tests required three weeks and were far
too complex for general use in 1967 the
federal government began its massive
field trials in cities from Danbury
Connecticut to Los Angeles inoculations
were given detailed records were kept on
vaccinees and controls and follow-up
blood studies gave evidence of antibody
response similar studies were done on
Taiwan where the vaccine proved 90%
effective during an epidemic in all the
trials involved scores of physicians
nurses laboratory technicians and nearly
50,000 children now with an approved
vaccine prospects are good that the
birth defects of rubella can be
eliminated it depends on the medical
profession and the parents of America